part three Rena with me carefully and
help guide me and what I'm actually
going to write for my working cuz it's
very important the way they communicate
this okay
it says what's the probability that this
particular student is extension one
maths if it is known that they chose
extension one English did I get the
order right yep okay so I'm gonna write
this we want to know if their extension
one Matz if it's known that their
extension one English
what are we you professor sagging bar
pipe whatever who'd that be very good
now that now by the way quick point
right this is clearly different
- this isn't it part two and part three
they're asking different things so the
order is very important when we think
about this right now when we have a
think about it we can do this in one of
two ways
okay before we just went straight to our
formula and then we looked at the
diagram let's try and do this in Reverse
just to make sure we're convinced of
what we've come up with right the
probability of this given that so let's
focus on this given that first what this
means is as we mentioned before I know
information so I can exclude some things
from my diagram right so let's come back
over here I think what was it is this 27
and if 42 is that right just doing it
from memory okay so who I've got one two
three four numbers who can I exclude on
this diagram I can exclude the 42 why
can I exclude the 42 they're not
involved in English or maths so they
certainly can't be one of these students
agreed so I'm just gonna wipe them off
for a second are there any numbers other
numbers I can get rid of I can get rid
of 95 I know this can't be it because
these students did not choose extension
English and that's kind of my condition
is there anyone else I can get rid of no
these guys are in my hallowed circle
okay so that's good so what I got now is
a new sample space it's over you
calculate this number right 56 it's up
there in red up the top right hand
corner okay so the my new sample space
right is that could I say that to be in
of E that is right that's exactly what
the formula would have told me if I just
recited it I came up the top
which is the particular group I'm
interested in within that the 27 or 29
it's a 29 right because I'm interested
in the people who do maths that's the
probability laughter right so this
number is 29 how I state that using my
probability and set notation it would be
in of what M intersect e now just quick
know it look up for a second
and make sure you look at this sorry let
me complete your fraction right this
number 29
doesn't it look familiar didn't we just
use this the 29 is here is the same as
the 29 up here right why is that the
same haha the intersection a intersect M
is the same as M intersect 8 so I could
actually say and you can see it here in
the diagram right sorry another color
these guys in here no matter which way
you look at it M intersect e equals e
intersect and so the way we would say
this the technical way is we would say
intersection and actually when you think
about it also Union they are commutative
that's what happens when you can just
switch the order like addition
modification and it makes no difference
okay
can I simplify that it's not right it's
done okay very good last one let's do
this one all together it's the
probability of can you tell me what to
write
what's it after M
I'm actually not going to say bar cuz
bar usually means the thing over the top
so I'm gonna put my pipe it's a a
compliment and actually that's called a
bar so anyway words notation you can see
what I mean right
alright so this is what I'm interested
in so I'm gonna go straight to the
formula here I didn't even need to think
that's the great thing about formulas
once you understand them you can simply
use them it puts things into autopilot
for you I'm going to write at the top
here this is my new favorable event so
it's going to be M intersect a
compliment
right all over and of a compliment
alright have a look what are the numbers
let's steal from the table why not have
a look here's a compliment right so
what's n of e compliment have a look
have a look it's not it's the whole row
isn't it
137 okay so there's my denominator and
then over the top M intersect a
compliment M a compliment
there's the intersection isn't it 95
flip the table walk off you're done okay
so when you think about it right both of
these tools have their own advantages
what you need to be able to do is
construct both of them and interpret
both of them equally well one last thing
before we finish because now you've got
a lot of tools your disposal right there
are roughly speaking I can think 1 2 3 4
tools that we can talk about I can't
think of a nice a canoe to come up with
that there are 4 main tools that we use
to visualize what is happening in the
sample space and the favorable events 2
of them are on the board right now what
would you call them what would you call
this thing this whole thing this object
up here it's a table right a table is
super useful ok what was this thing we
called Venn diagram right what was the
object we usually think about the dice
the array also called a dot diagram I
take it back this 4/5 the tree Dyer
which we looked at recently now the last
one which most of us often forget is
just if it's a simpler situation and
frequently in advance it will be just
list out the options right if you are
flipping two coins and
is heads and tails don't for a Venn
diagram just list them out there are
only four options head head head tail
tail head tail tail you're done okay
before someone's finished drawing their
circles okay so don't forget you have
all these options and being able to see
that you can equivalently represent a
situation with any of them is really
important all right I'm gonna shut up a
get out of your way if you have any
questions I'll come around to you or did
you want to yep sorry you're talking
Matt this one for how did we know I was
using this one as opposed to what might
have your other option Ben 124 which is
this one okay this is actually really
important Leslie's asked a good question
and I'm gonna see because lens is the
only one he's asked it unless you're
about to ask you exactly the same
question so that indicates to me
hopefully you all know the answer to
this because you didn't ask so I wanna
make sure I've still got everyone's
attention thank you says the question
was and that's a good question from
there's the why did I use the 137 that's
the sky as opposed to the 124 because
they're both plausible they'll even give
you similar answers anyway why this one
we recognize okay hold on let me just
make sure I've got your later he talks
out a column usually by this column here
so this column here if we were to use
this one 24 which I did not use right
it would include this group and this
group these two groups here now this
group here as I was putting out this
group is problematic
why shouldn't I include this have a look
at the question
the condition that the piece of
information that you know is that this
is not an extension one English student
so that's why I should pretend that this
doesn't exist in fact I'm pretending
this whole role does not exist which is
why I only get left with this row
hence the 137 does that clarify cool